[Music]
all right Erica
Erica where'd you grow up where are you
from originally I'm from a small town in
Mississippi called ayuka
um it's one of those towns that you
blink you miss it literally driving
across the Interstate 72
it's a one horse town
tell me about your family
um I've grew up for the
pretty Grayson family you know like my
mom died when I was 11. I moved with her
sister
um at that time because my dad was a
crackhead um he also had issues with
like
um running a porn ring in the next
County over I'm from a conservative
State I mean so mind you like it's it's
watching porn is damn near illegal you
can't even buy beer where I'm from so I
mean
running a
porn ring in a hotel next door is not
something that was looked too highly
upon so you can imagine this is as my
mom died so my mom just died when he got
arrested so going to school in fifth
grade
um wasn't very easy for
for me or my sisters so
um
yeah
in the abuse
um not for my family
um
not from my family no
um it was um
I abuse myself a lot
um
I started I started cutting myself
around that time but
um
no abuse for my family
I um
well
I
I had sex when I was like 12 years old
for a crack with my Dad's friend
um
you know I'm pretty sure my dad had
something to do with it
um
can't prove it so
but I mean who would go into a room with
a 12 year old boy and ask him to suck
their dick you know
well in the crack fight
I mean that's not something a normal
person normal adult would do I could
never I couldn't see myself doing it so
I mean it had to be a suggested
um
idea
what kind of kid were you in high school
huh what kind of kid were you in high
school
um
I was the
I was
meta extrovert I was
down for anything type of
person but I was also the promiscuous
you know I was who
a lot of the people found
um
they're
sexual orientation with I guess you say
um I was the experiment
the most part A lot of that had to do
with
um
I had I had gotten caught
having sex with um
my school teacher like my gym teacher
like it was a it was a scandal
um he obviously got fired and went to
jail
um
I got sent away for a little while but
when I came back you know I had learned
a whole lot more when I was gone you
know I went you know to Detroit Michigan
with my aunt
tears
a Christian you know allegedly but
up there it's way more like Fast Track
and like so much more to take home you
know like
I
I guess you'd say like I was
the boy bicycle the gym room you know
like everybody knew what I was doing but
nobody would admit it you know like
it was fun
you know I was getting high all the time
like at this point I was
taking oxygen um smoking cocaine on a
regular basis I just went in that not
this is like high school like ninth
grade high school like um
so
yeah what would you consider yourself
gay or trans or um I consider myself
trans now like I mean then it was it was
I couldn't even dream of
becoming Erica back home it was it was
not a thing that could be done I mean
yeah you had you had gay women and some
gay men you hear about you know or that
that
best friend people that's been living
together for 50 years you know that you
know never got married never kids that
type of thing but no transgender
anything so that had probably a lot to
do with
um
dude why I ran away you know
getting the net that's in the rules like
tariff again
um
so I'm a boy at this point you know I'm
a corn fed white boy recommendous I
still haven't still had to work the farm
I still had to you know play sports I
mean I was still a straight acting
straight appearing
um masculine
teenage boy you know I mean
a really good looking management
like I would [__] me if I was me you
know you're not saying a lot
um
but you know like
I guess when it came out to the adults
and
the propriety of my town if you want to
call Amos Bates in this [__]
hypocritical [__] you know
it kind of made it public you know what
I was doing and so then I was just a
[__]
you know everybody I [__] I was back
to them too but yeah I [__] them you
know at this point I [__] them but
I was a [__]
do you think you were born
gay or do you think you became gay from
something that happened I always I you
know I um I can I can always remember I
was very boring I was doing boring gay I
always remember I always remember you
know wanting to suck dick like I
remember like in my my cousins I
remember like you know
nine ten years old you know like or even
younger than that because
my mom was still alive
um going into my cousin's closet you
know like Undercovers and sucking their
dicks you know like I mean I I remember
that I remember the smell I remember you
know because it's like always sleeping
bags it's whatever because this is what
we covered ourselves up with this oh
it's sleeping bags you know like I don't
know if you ever smelled like taking a
sleeping bag out of the closet actually
been there for a winter or whatever and
you just it just smells like oh camping
gear so I remember very very vividly
um
are these good memories for you or
traumatic oh very good memories I mean
like I mean I like I I I remember like I
I use those those memories to masturbate
like I remember like
to get myself off you know like you know
like without getting without you know
getting myself off you know it was they
were very
um
uh
they're good memories they were good man
I didn't have ugly cousins
um
yeah they were good memories
um what's your what was your
relationship like with your parents
um my mom died when I was my mom died
when I was 11. so but up until then like
I was mama's boy like I mean I slept
with my mom until I was 11 years old I
did I'm not sure I'm gonna say it it was
me
my sister didn't know oh I'm gonna say
her name
um and my older sister my mama slept on
the outside my oldest are sipping on the
other outside and me and my middle
sister slept in the middle you know we
take turn to sleep beside Mama but by
the time the morning came when nobody
seems like Mama because she didn't went
and living room couch so
um
but I had a good relationship with my
mom you know like
I think if she'd been alive
um
if she if she was still alive
today I think things would not have
happened the way they did
at least
on my end
you know like
I would never have
I I know I would be gay because she was
just that Aunt you know like like she
was just that woman like you just go
through her and be like you know
this was going on she was the one that
all my cousins went to when they had a
problem
she was the one that you know
you call when you need a six-pack she
was the one you calling you need to ride
home because you've got the girls were
drunk you know it was just a very small
town like Hick Life you know
um she was just a good woman my dad on
the other hand was a
um a well-traveled I'm more like my dad
like I totally more like my dad like me
and my oldest sister like we are the
adventurers my dad was one of those
my dad was like a just a glow doer like
I mean like he didn't like my dad was
saying like you know he said you know
son I don't know everything
but I know a little bit about everything
and I didn't realize how much that
Ranger until
I strove to
do the exact same thing you know one
person can't know everything but you
could read about just about anything and
everything you know just
lazy learning is what I call it like I I
go to college I take college classes for
fun I mean that's just what I do
just because I like to learn but
um he was the more
promiscuous like you know like
he did the whole hooker thing like the
guy where he buy hookers or you know
like I can't ever remember him telling
me that he ever had a homosexual
experience but he did you know tell me
all about like
you know he'd gotten my first prostitute
uh did you do that I mean
I can't say that didn't good because I
mean like he was a female and I was like
you know this ain't working right you
know this old crackhead prostitute thing
I wanted to do that you know I'd rather
have sex with my friend right here you
know that was with me you know and I did
I chose my friend
um
the crackhead got paid for free for
nothing but
um
and then like my dad like made up his
tone for
everything before he died he did he made
up for everything that
you could think that he did was wrong
you know I I can't say that what my dad
did was wrong because or I can't say
that my dad everything my dad did was
wrong because
I don't know you know I don't know what
he was thinking at the time you know I
can say that I went and I would have
been things the same way that he did him
but you know who who am I I'm just one
person
I mean he had a lot of followers on um
what was that you got mail that went
down he had AOL yeah he had a lot of
friends on that so I mean like
the porn ring thing I mean I'm not sure
if if it had to do with kids or anything
like that I didn't get to read into it
too much because it was a it was um
sometimes kids away from us
but um
when when the um when the sheriff of my
town like put me on blast
um
it really I really started like doing
drugs hardcore I started slamming up at
that point
um
and just didn't give a [__] I didn't
care just didn't do what
didn't want didn't want to live so I
mean who cares like you mean like you
know like
I don't want to go to church so I
[__] took off when I you know
I went to the interstate 72
. it's a ride to Interstate 65 i-565 and
um
made it down
to Interstate 10 and like
mind you like I had never been like
I would just I went to Florida with my
family for vacations but I never been
anywhere by myself ever
you know like except when I went to
Miami in Detroit you know but even then
like I was picked up at the airport and
dropped off at the airport like I never
went anywhere
with my own accord like just
to go do it but I ran away I did
and um
I got as far as Dothan Alabama I don't
know if you
you're familiar with the South but
Dothan Alabama like
there's some it's a little it's an Old
Town Old Town Alabama off Interstate 10.
just after Interstate Tim Enterprise I
think is where the team picks up
um
that's what I got in America pilot
trucks up and um I don't know if you
know it's the one with the little boy on
the um I think it was pilot I'm pretty
sure
no yeah it was pilot because I had a
little boy on the side and instead of
Palestine
um and I met this
truck driver he looked like he would
full a freaking uh
a Baptist preacher because I mean this
man looked like Grandpa Walton I mean
you could not tell me this man wasn't
his grandpa you couldn't tell me this
guy would fool Jesus I mean literally
um
he made me feel like you know like he
wanted to help me like genuinely wanted
to help me and me like a dumb naive
little punk I told him what I'd done you
know if I run away and no nobody knew
where I was at and no my sister doesn't
know I'm coming
but it should be surprised when I get
there
and then he was all too willing to help
me get there you know
you know and I I didn't think anything
of it like I mean I just really felt
like somebody I had got a break and
someone wanted to help me for a change
you know
and um
you know he helped himself is what he
did
last thing I remember after that he got
me something to eat and he got it was
cold so
um he got me some hot chocolate and he
got me like
it was a pop I'm pretty sure it was a
part part it was a power pastry
um that's the best thing I remember
before I woke up in the basement
like in this basement was just like you
think basically you have it meant a
picture of what it basically looks like
no it's not like anything that you would
think basically look like I mean it
looked like a freaking like a summer
Cottage down there look it looked homely
it looked like you know like it was it
looked like something
that was meant to be appeasing
but it's far from it because
my bed set in the wall
you know it was like a
ultimately it was a bomb shelter because
like um where the house sits it sits
right off the nearest Jacksonville Air
Force Base right there off um
listening that street
I'll think of in a second
um the 17 isn't it's a highway name but
um
it's just just off the base you know he
was keeping you there
he did like for for a year and a half I
was I was in this man's
in this men's basement like I mean like
in this man like just
anytime like so be alone I was alone I
was alone I Was Alone
um
I I did end up falling in love with him
you know um I never willingly in the
beginning had sex with him
um
I know that
there was drugs in the food there hadn't
been drugs some some type of drug on the
food because
I would go to sleep after just about
every meal like I mean like and it's not
it wasn't big meals so I mean I can't
contribute to that
but I know that he [__] me when I was
asleep
I know that I mean because at this point
I wasn't a top I mean I was on the top I
wasn't never bottom I'd never been
[__] before like at all
you know like
but I knew that I'd been [__] when I
woke up were there other people that he
did this with no um before me yeah there
was there was I don't know who they were
I don't I don't know who
the names were never released in
in
um any of the reports because like
it was a whole there was a different
case
um but there were other victims I mean
it was easy to see that like you know
like
when you're when you're in somewhere by
yourself and you had a way of keeping
track of time you find ways to do it
like in prison you know you do a check
on the wall you do a notch on the bed
you know and I would look around
and there was like you could just see
the creativity of someone else's
form of calendar you know like
like the notches and bed posts
um or not the bedpost because the
bedpost is a wall
um
chalk on the wall
um scratches the glass plexiglass mind
you
um
because there was no way outside like
you were in a you were in a still bunker
though the Sun that was coming in from
the window was not a real sign
it was [__] Plexiglas window because
you know like in a basement like
um especially like in in Wetlands like
they have the drop down the crate the
water grade over it so things don't get
in there and so it was all false like
the whole the whole thing was said to be
just one big image that wasn't it was a
torture chamber I mean it was a torture
chamber
this man's appetites were just so
things that I had never experienced
before you know and I find myself as a
pretty experienced individual because I
mean I was I was a [__] you know like I
mean back home I mean I had sex all
kinds of people but like he had like
really weird
really weird tasting sexual appetites
what kind of things would you do
um he liked he like um
you like you like blood you like to you
know people like to believe me you know
um
which I think is kind of hot I mean now
I think it's kind of hot but then it was
scary
you know
um
I used to have scars on my chest you
know their stuff scars my chest they're
faded now um
but it was it was weird like I mean
um
he likes even like he likes Scott I mean
like he just
he would give me freaking like like
laxative and while he was eating my ass
he
you know I would ask me to shut his
mouth I mean like you know I'd paint a
jug just like that one and and he drink
down I mean yeah this is really just now
mind you I'm a kid I'm a kid okay he
said scat and water sports I've never
already I was 14 when I got there
wow so when I left I was 16.
you weren't going to school
yeah I've been away from home
I ran away so at this point like I mean
there is a there is a
what we call Amber Alerts there was an
amber alert with my name on it
you know
but I guess they just stopped looking
like
I don't see how they could have stopped
looking because I mean like I don't
think I could ever let my child or my
nephew or my niece be just gone
like that I mean like I don't I just
don't see it did your family think you
were dead they did
you thought I was dead
they did
yeah
about a year I guess okay
you know imagine I've had a lot of
counseling since then
advocate deprogrammed
um
if you know if you know what that means
I
deprogram that's crazy
I wouldn't testify against him but I
didn't have a choice you would what I
wouldn't testify against him oh you
wouldn't testify against him I wouldn't
speak anything
I didn't say anything bad about him
why not because I loved him I fell in
love with him I mean like it's later on
I found out that it wasn't there wasn't
love it was it was um
it's um
it's kind of like better woman syndrome
um you know where the wife you know like
loves her husband but you know
she doesn't love him she gets beat by
him she runs away she runs back to him
just get beat again
send me some of that but like on a
different
scale I guess like I mean it's called
Stockholm syndrome how old was he
um
68 when I met him yeah so like when he
was 68 you were 14 yeah
so mind you like I said it looked like
Grandpa Walton if you can put the image
in your head Grandpa Watson I would
never in my life ever sleep with anybody
like that now like I mean like could not
but over time I every time like I Okay
so
we assuming like the the reward
um uh you know it's it's you get a prize
for an action you know so like
um he would do things for me like I
would gain
um
I would gain like um how you say no no
it was prizes like like I eventually got
to go upstairs you know like to eat at
the table eventually got to go into town
the farmer's market yeah
walk right outside and never thought
never thought of leaving aside never
thought of being inside were there other
you think there were other young boys
before you oh yeah most definitely
absolutely they this man was so like he
he knew he knew exactly what to do when
to do it you know
science so this is something that it was
so methodical in in a way like now that
I look back on him because like I have a
um Behavioral Science
um degree you know in abnormal
psychology and concentration in criminal
deviancy so that's that's what I wanted
to know why this was happening to me why
this happened to me and what happens to
so many people every day it happens to
millions of people and it just goes
unnoticed because either they die or
there's no there's no coming
I'm a statistic of like two percent
you know
I shouldn't there's no reason why I
should have left that man's basement
should have been dead how did you leave
well okay so I told you I ran away I ran
away from my house in Mississippi to go
to my sister's house in Florida
Jacksonville Florida
where it is where did this happen
um in Jacksonville Florida Jacksonville
yeah
so the Arab neighbors so my sister was a
lady
um
so on the weekends they have farmers
markets I told you
um
we went out one weekend actually no it
was it was the farm market that weekend
it was the air show
that we went to that they had this um
the
the Boost and things that you go
shopping at you know
um
so when I see my sister like like do the
crowd I see my sister and she see me too
you know and we just when our eyes
locked our eyes locked and just like
I told him we gotta go you know we gotta
go you know I mean we left but mind you
like my sister's like way over there and
there's a whole bunch of people like
this is the Navy town so there's
hundreds of people like in between me
and her I'm never sure how I saw her but
we did
he took me home
and you know like we had sex I said
in the basement still I still step in
baseball I've never not split in the
basement I always slept in the basement
I was whether I had sex in his room or
whatever I always went down to my room
I locked my door you know I I always was
in the basement
I'm not sure why that was probably
because you know he
you know sleep in the same bed before
night would probably
be too like much for him I'm not sure
but
um
I know that
with two
almost two weeks it went by almost
it was like 13 days it went by and I see
my sister at the um gas station on the
corner that's a Wilson Drive
between 103rd
and
Blanding Boulevard
gas station and
I don't know like
I just couldn't like
the whole time I'm blocking a half of my
house dude
the entire time
there's a block and a half of my
sister's house
the entire time
she wants maybe she wants me to say you
know
she called the cops you know
[Applause]
um
it was a federal case because I had
crossed state lines so
it was a it was a big ordeal you know
but I
essentially they like
let me go I'm begging him let me go they
let me go you know like was it just a
coincidence that your sister lived in
Jacksonville Florida from Mississippi
she was stationed I mean I'm not sure
like I think
because he's a truck driver so and when
I told him like I I said to I set my own
trap you know like I told the man that
nobody was the that nobody knows that
that she didn't know I was coming but
that she was in the military and then
she was in Jacksonville and you know I I
obviously you know told me he lived in
Jacksonville because I mean that's where
that's where I was going and he would
gladly take me you know I didn't know
that I didn't know where my sister I was
going to call her when I got there
you know I couldn't tell him where she
lives and he he didn't know where she
lived either because I
because I didn't know
that that was a coincidence that whole
really ironic coincidence but because
Jacksonville is not no little city it's
the largest city landmass was in the
United States
not population wise but land mass Wise
It's the largest city in the United
States
um
that's a lot of land
so this man eventually got caught
so when they let me they let me go
like
he was waiting for me like he was just
like I walked in the door he was sitting
the table
my door because my door said the
basement was right behind where I
satinate so my door was open he was in
my seat sitting in my chair
and he said
I knew you'd come back they always do
and
I went downstairs and for the first time
in a long time he locked me in the
basement like he locked the door and
then that's when
the marshals and everybody he came in
and that's when the arrest was made you
know
they followed me they sent me yet very
you know they he could have killed me
you know he could have easily killed me
between the time
of all that because I had able to sleep
before they came you know they didn't
they didn't show up right away like not
in Chinese that's not how they work you
know that's not how they work I even
think he went out first
and then
they came in
pretty sure that he went he left and
came back and then they came in
[__] that
so yeah
then eventually you came to LA
um I did come to La
um
let's see I was
19. how do you know 38.
you've been here how long
almost 20 years
um
that's a whole another where you've been
living on the streets
um I did I've been in prison for 13
years oh really yeah
huh what was that for
um I have a
sales case I've got
a attempted murder
I beat the attempted murder I got
dropped to a um a solidated weapon with
a great blood injury
that was for
I
almost killed this dude with a Tyrone
because he had my friend
um
my friend's kid held hostage rope sack
this guy was a non-pedophile
he's known
he's known to just give it to people
like just pass it out like it was candy
AIDS I mean HIV I mean you know because
it was done to him so he felt like he
was done in Injustice and
he thought that he was just gonna just
take my left field because I mean my
friends my friends kids man they're like
mine you know like I they're
especially the good ones you know like
[__] like
the bathrooms I love him just as much as
I love the good ones you know like you
know but the bad ones you know they need
to ask him a few more times before they
like they did it but
I don't want any of them to have to go
through what I went through to get it
right
I still don't have it right but
nobody should have to go through what I
went through not to not to learn a
lesson not just learn you know
it's okay to go to school it's okay to
go to church it's okay to do things you
don't have to be a bad person you don't
have to be a bad kid you don't have to
show your ass who you're showing your
ass for
because you in the end you're still
going to do what you're told you know
like just do it right the first time
it's worth it
I mean
I've I
try to kill myself so many times he was
like
I stabbed myself in the neck I've
overlooked something no
on purpose
you know some people don't do it on
purpose like they accidentally I
every day I try to overdo something you
know I just can't like my daughter so I
um
what is your drug now
I do um how do you support yourself
um
I saw other I still I thought I mean I
I prostitute I mean like I mean I'm not
gonna lie like I mean
I mean Alex shout out right now because
I mean I've been up for a few days and
like I'm just going through it my health
isn't really good right now
um
I have AIDS
had it since 2009
um
no I have never given anybody else HIV
I am very cautious with how I
I know that all my clients know so I
don't there's no there's no transparency
with me are you on medications that they
give yeah I take um I take two retro
photos
enter the table and
um I can't think of the name of this
second one because I just started
um
but I haven't been taking them um I just
now started taking right dude like
I've waited too long
I just I lost I lost six more pounds
since three days ago
you know I just left the doctors jump
before I came over here
I got medication right there
um
wasting like I mean I'm wasting away
nothing can't gain weight can't
for the life of me I get boost
exceptional drinks like I just where do
you sleep
right now I sleep in the Rest Hotel
um paid for by an HIV program
um
I hope I am going to be in Frisco
tonight
leave for Frisco tonight maybe
you're going to San Francisco I would
like to
um
I think it's time for me I've had a
reset in 20 years you know
and um now that I see
the damage I've done to myself like
if I don't do it now I'm gonna die I
won't I won't make it another month
if you'd like to live all over again
what would you have done differently
sorry
I'm gonna go to church
let's go to church that's all I had to
do
[Music]
it doesn't pay
it doesn't
not listening to your parents does it
make you a
badass does it make you [__]
it makes you stupid you know because
you're stupid
all right all you gotta do is just do go
to school and go to church it's the only
thing I was required oh and
wash the dishes out there that's it
I had a free ride you know like I had it
made dude I made
I haven't seen my family in 20 years
nobody in my family in 20 years nobody
talking on the phone but I haven't seen
anybody in 20 years
look at the pictures on
online and I see
these people I don't even know who they
are because
I still see them as
how they were when I left
in 20 years has passed by and for
somebody who was already oh
20 years just uh puts a lot on you you
know I've lost almost all my aunts and
uncles I haven't seen any of them you
know
and I want to be healthy enough to make
the trip back home
before my aunt dies because if she dies
and I don't get to see her I say goodbye
I don't know about I'm awake I won't
make it through that I won't
as it is I haven't talked to her in over
a month
it's just
life is too short as it is
to just [__] it off
because you want to be a spoiled brat
because I like to say this is endnote
like you know just
go to school go to church wash dishes
it may seem like freaking [__]
meaningless task time I promise you like
a little goes a long way
a little effortless no way
there we go what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life
that um
family is the most important thing
no I'm not talking about like you know
just your blood family I mean like
family because you don't have to be
related to be family because I
I have two two females that are
my rider dies you know like
I would call in my sisters or my real
sisters any day because they've been
there
they've been there you know
um
the family is important um
because um
who's gonna be there
to even
let anybody else know that you lived
that you had a life that you were
somebody you know you weren't just a
story you know until Christmas time that
you were actually a person that you were
you know
my street mother died a couple months
ago
um
you know she was very she was an icon
she was an icon she was a wonderful
person she was a soldier she was she
thought you know for gay right she
fought for transgender she fought tooth
and now I mean she bled she's she
she bled you know
for my people and
she got [__] 45 days into accounting
ice box looking like [__] something
of a Tarzan movie
you know
family is important
but make sure that you know
you don't have ulterior motives
because
not everybody's out to get you
you can tell the difference you know
Erica thank you so much for sharing your
story no problem very interesting
thank you I wish you lots of luck hope
you make it to San Francisco yeah
I can help you get up there yeah
just need a ticket